[Music]
the penance for all you need to get out
because I've been checking Facebook and
there was lots of messages sitting there
saying you know it was a tsunami risk
and do what you need to get out am I HD
safe here I was getting my car really
just putting you know the emergency
stuff on the card ended already and then
sirens when we might as well discuss
they were very very loud here that knife
I guess it would absolutely still on the
south carex pages and I think maybe
that's peanuts a lot of people
definitely need to have them happen
people didn't really know what to do
[Music]
we're close to the coast but are we sent
closer we need to get out
[Music]
you